[Music]
brian is in california hey brian welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave how's it going thank you for
taking my call my pleasure sir how can i
help
yeah um so i'm just gonna read out this
thing that i wrote here it says uh
i'm debt free i have an emergency fund i
have a business emergency fund as well
and i'm on baby step 3b and i just want
to know if i made the right decision
i've worked for seven years in the
construct in the construction industry
since the age of 18
i am now 25
making really good money
in my own business
and i feel bad like i let my ex-employer
down
did i make a good decision leaving my
old company my family make me feel bad
like i charge too much i have many
clients that are happy to pay my rate
and honestly i charge what an average
professional handyman charges
in my area
so what did you used to make
um
i need thirty dollars an hour
then what do you well okay i'm gonna
show what's that equate to a year
like uh 55 000. okay so you're making 60
grand a year and what do you make now
now like 120.
i'm confused where the mistake might be
yeah it's just
um my old company called me earlier
today
and they want a decision and they want
to know if i'm going to come back
because initially i told them i was
going to take a break no i don't have
brain damage
all right am i missing something coleman
i what i well i don't know why your
family's making you feel badly about
leaving this company when you've doubled
over you've doubled your salary and
you're working for yourself i mean my
goodness i just don't understand i'm not
sure what's missing either but you don't
need to feel guilty or bad i don't know
if they're worried about stability but
there's this myth sometimes
with our friends and family members who
don't have an entrepreneurial spirit
maybe they've never worked for a true
entrepreneur maybe they've never done it
themselves and so they think government
jobs or well if you work for a bigger
company it's more stable the fact of the
matter is is that you are more stable
working for you with the skill sets that
you have because i got to tell you
something during the pandemic what we
saw are folks like you were booming with
their businesses and their work so i
don't know what's missing either but you
need to stay working for yourself based
on what i've heard
so the only reason you would go back to
work for the other company is because
your relatives say you charge too much
and it's evil that you've become wealthy
doing this at 25 years old
or
or you would go back to work there
because somehow you have some kind of
misguided loyalty to a company that used
to pay you less than half of what you
make now
yeah it's more yeah the last part you
know i feel like
yeah okay i just know
there's never been anyone that worked at
ramsey that left here and made double
that i suggested they should come back
for half
never okay never have i suggested that
because i actually like the people that
work here and if they can make double
somewhere else i would like that for
them
generally speaking these days that's not
possible because we pay so dadgum much
now but in the old days when we were
getting started we didn't pay a lot and
people would leave and go make more
money and i just had to help them leave
and go with i love you and go make more
money that's awesome go do it uh but i
don't have to do that these days thank
god but the um yeah because but but you
need to keep doing what you're doing
so uh brian i had a relative uh several
years ago that loved me deeply
and she was a very very sweet little
lady
and her husband had worked in corporate
america at the same job for 38 years and
she was so thankful that he had this
steady job
and every time i would see her
she would ask me when i was going to get
a real job
the last time she asked me that in that
calendar year i made more in that one
year than her husband made in his entire
working lifetime
but she was still waiting on me to get a
real job
yeah i hear you and so it was not
because she was bad she actually loved
me and she was worried about me
because she was worried it was unstable
and that being self-employed is unstable
and what you find out when you're
self-employed like you are
especially when you're a handyman and
you're probably a one or a two-man show
you find out that you are actually the
secret sauce at the end of the day at
the end of the day you are what uh
really you can count on and by the way
it was that way all along
just that way all along
when that guy worked for corporate
america that that was my relative who
was a sweet man he was a nice man i'm
not belittling him at all but it was
just the mathematics were humorous
of her point of me getting a real job
and she just desired security
uh to the point that she misjudged where
security comes from
and security comes from your ability to
get up leave the cave and kill something
and drag it home and you have proven
your ability to do that young man i'm
very proud of you you should keep doing
what you're doing
yeah well done thank you
so much dave thank you so much thank you
god bless you
wow
i talked to a handyman the other day you
made 300 last year oh yeah this is
stinking because you can't get nobody to
show up if you just show up you can
charge about anything you want to charge
yeah it's pretty amazing it's a premium
service and you know that young man
right there wouldn't you love to have
him in your house fixing stuff oh
let's just belabor this point about the
size of a company equating to stability
we've all seen large companies
completely evaporate or lay off people
by the thousands okay i mean peloton did
it recently they were the hottest uh one
of the hottest consumer products and
during the pandemic until they weren't
until they weren't remember enron go
look that story up a public company so
you know this idea that well i'm going
to put my fortune in somebody else's
hands and that's stable well that's just
a bunch of garbage especially when you
work for yourself you got sound
financial principles here's the thing
you always
work for yourself when you work for a
company
you just have one client that's right
you got one customer yeah that's it and
when you work for yourself and you have
a bunch of customers it's no different
you know and so i've got millions of
customers
and uh but when you work for a company
and you're you know james has one
customer as far as i know
we're his only customer ramsey solutions
and that's not a bad thing that's not
the end of the world but this idea that
somehow that you're not self-employed at
the end of the day your responsibility
your life is your responsibility and
when you acquit when you turn that
responsibility over to someone else when
you
dispatch it to someone else in the name
of security and you say okay i'm no
longer have to worry about that because
that company's going to worry about
it you just sacrificed something so i we
tell our people around here they're all
self-employed we say it all the time
it's one of our 14 core values you're
self-employed you're self-employed
you're self-employed act like you're
self-employed act like you own this
place act like when you see a piece of
paper on the ground pick it up like you
own the place
be responsible act like you're
self-employed act like you're
self-employed
and
even if you're not technically you'll
always prosper with that mentality